it's guilty verdicts on both
counts um ali harby ali found guilty in
a very short jury deliberation
of the murder of sir david amos the mp
he stabbed to death
in his constituency surgery last october
and also guilty of preparing acts of
terrorism i'm not clear yet whether ali
harvey ali the 26 year old man described
as a fanatical radicalized terrorist
will be sentenced
today but he's some clearly facing
a mandatory life sentence in prison for
the murder of sir david amos
the prosecution
had described this as a cold calculated
murder
carried out because of a warped twisted
and violent
ideology
carried out said the prosecutor at the
start of this three-week trial by a
bloodthirsty committed
fanatical radicalized islamic terrorist
now unusually ali harvey ali had
admitted
stabbing to death the mp
but he had denied
murder throughout his trial um he'd
given evidence in his own defense
and had
said that he didn't believe that the
word murder
was legal
he said he explained
during his evidence that he had killed
the mp
because
sir david amis had voted
to bomb syria bomb isis positions in
syria going back to 2015. so ali habi
ali who had also considered killing
other mps including cabinet ministers
had singled out sir david amos according
to his evidence in court
because he had supported the killing of
muslims in syria
he went on to say
killing sir david amos
might stop more muslims being killed
his lawyer
had argued uh towards the end of this
trial but although the jury had here had
heard compelling evidence of ali harby's
guilt
he wasn't guilty
said the lawyer the defense lawyer to
the jurors until you say so
well the judge finished his summing up
at 20 past 12 today and
by our rough calculation it took the
jury about 20 minutes or so
to decide
that ali harvey ali was guilty on both
verdicts
martin it's extraordinary the trial has
been extraordinary hasn't it and it
heard how um he spent years hatching
this plot and as you said he did
research a number of high-profile
targets all of them political michael
gove dominic raab and sakir stammer
before he settled on david amos
yes according to the prosecution this
uh attack on sir david amos or a
murderous attack on an mp had been
planned for some years in fact the
prosecution
uh pointed out that the knife
a very long knife that ali harbi ali
used to stab sir david amis had been
bought
five years earlier
but he had wrecked and certainly wrecked
the home of michael gove
a number of times according to the
evidence
produced in court
but dominic raab had also been one of
his potential targets so to
uh sakir stama the the labour leader but
according to the prosecution
uh he settled on uh sir david amos
and travelled from his home in north
london
on that day and in fact julius was shown
cctv from a number of cameras that
plotted ali harvey's journey from north
london to sir david amos's essex
constituency in south end and
i think by anybody's measure uh
interpretation uh ali habibi looked very
calm
strolling along the streets of north
london and then the streets of south end
almost nonchalantly carrying a knapsack
in which at the prosecution he carried
the knife
he had tricked his way into a meeting
with david amos who was holding his
regular
friday
surgery
for constituents he had claimed to be
planning to move into the constituency
so he had very easy access to sir david
amos who
clearly had no idea of what was about to
happen in fact according to witnesses it
wasn't really until the moment that ali
harvey produced the knife
in his face-to-face confrontation with
the mp
that sir david amos uh suddenly became
aware of the danger he faced he was
stabbed 21 times there were also
uh defensive wounds to his hands so
it sounds as though he put up what fight
he could
but clearly succumbed to 21
stab wounds
martin brunt thank you so much go ahead
martin
sorry i was just about to tell you that
i was asking the question about
sentencing i'm i'm told
by a colleague that ali habi ali will be
sentenced on wednesday
but he does face
a mandatory life sentence of course
it'll be up to the judge
to decide the minimum sentence
that he must serve in prison before the
chance of parole of course he could give
him a whole life sentence
okay martin brunt for us outside the old
bailey martin thank you so much